bonjour Sylvie méien bonjour vous êtes
historienne une historienne remontée
après les propos de l'ancien Premier
ministre et candidat à la primaire de la
droite et du centre pour la
présidentielle François filon rapide
rappel nous sommes le 28 août dernier
nous sommes à sabless sur Sart et
François filon s'exprime sur
l'enseignement de l'histoire un
enseignement à revoir à revoir le passé
qui est honteux et source
d'interrogation et dit-il la France ne
peut pas être coupable d'avoir voulu
faire partager sa culture au peuples
d'Afrique d'Asie et d'Amérique du Nord
la France n'a pas inventé l'esclavage et
là vous avez bondi de votre chaise
Sylvie mélien pourquoi oui parce que ce
sont des des propos qui deviennent assez
r récurrent euh souvent cet ans dernier
euh on entend des hommes politiques des
femmes des femmes des des hommes
politiques qui tiennent ce genre de
propos et et qui s'attaquent à cette
partie de l'histoire et cette partie de
l'histoire que que beaucoup veulent
renier notamment en France cette partie
de l'histoire ben c'est c'est la nôtre
et et nous faisons partie de cette
nation et évidemment l'histoire de
l'esclavage l'impression d'être renié
lorsque vous entendez quelqu'un comme
François Filion qui était quand même
chef de gouvernement parler ainsi benah
écoutez oui parce que quand il dit que
il voudrait revoir un petit peu ce qui
qui qui va dans les manuels scolaires
revoir cette histoire faire en sorte que
les Français soi fiers de leur histoire
l'esclavage fait partie de l'histoire de
France la France est une terre de
métissage et il n'y a pas qu'une mémoire
de la France il y a des mémoires chaque
chaque partie du territoire français
c'est une histoire et est-ce que en
France de façon globale de façon général
on a envie d'entendre ces poussières d'î
ces territoires éloignés qui me
remettent sans cesse le couvert sur
cette question de l'esclavage est-ce que
est-ce que les Français de France ont
envie d'entendre
ça les Français de France ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on serait moins
français parce qu'on n'est pas en France
hexagonale je vous pose la question nous
ne sommes pas de des Français de de
seconde zone nous sommes des citoyens à
partentière et donc nous avons une
hisire la bragne une histoire la cor a
une histoire et vous avez l'impression
d'être considéré comme par exemple des
Français de seconde zone parce que des
hommes de premier plan des femmes de
premier plan rejette cette partie de de
l'histoire je ne considère pas que je
suis une citoyenne de seconde zone je
suis une citoyenne à part
entière mon histoire qui est une
histoire particulière doit faire partie
des manuel scolaire souvent vous
entendez des personnes d'un certain âge
dire qu'à l'école ils ont appris nos
ancêtres les Gaulois euh mes ancêtres ne
sont pas Gaulois j'ai en moi je porte en
moi une histoire douloureuse une
histoire que tout le monde doit
connaître en France cette histoire doit
faire partie d'Emmanuel scolaire parce
qu'elle est partie intégrante de
l'histoire de France c'est pas c'est pas
l'histoire des martiniquis ou l'histoire
des Guadeloupéens ou l'histoire des des
Calédoniens ou je ne sais quel autre
département
d'outrem dès que le toutes ces
l'esclavage la traite négrière toutes
ces parties de l'histoire la colonie la
colonisation ça fait partie de
l'histoire de France et elle doit être
enseignée François filon a évoqué cette
notion de partage et alors paspr
vraiment alors le partage non j'ai pas
pris C pourqu parce qu'il parlait d'un
partage positif il sous-entendait un
partage positif bien fait positif de la
colonisation française ça rappelle un
texte he oui oui qui n'est pas si
lointain euh non le partage s fait de
façon brutale il s'appuie sur par le fer
par le feu et la Bible en et la Bible
euh oui parce qu'il dit que la France
est terre de de de Chrétien de
christianisme mais il ne faut pas
oublier que la France euh la France avec
l'Église euh ont participé c'est vrai
que la la France n'a pas initié
l'esclavage mais ils ont participé en
tout cas à ce que euh à la mise en place
de cette de cet esclavage ils ont Louis
XIV des rois on Louis XI ils ont
légiféré et ils ont admis euh la la la
traite négrière et l'esclavage et
euh cet esclavage cette colonisation a
fait partie de euh d' l' ensemble de
choses qui a permis à la France de
s'enrichir et d'être aujourd'hui l'une
des plus grandes nations françaises
nation duond ex la colonisation la
traite négrière l'esclavage a permis à
la France d'être ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui elle a participé à la
richesse de la France elle a
participé le les différents territoires
d'utr m permettent à la France d'avoir
un rayonnement sur l'ensemble des océans
et ça on ne peut pas le renier est-ce
que nous pourrions considérer que la
langue de François Filion a fourché lors
de ce discours prononcé assbl sur Sart
en principe quand on écrit petite phrase
malheureuse je ne pense pas euh je ne
pense pas quand on écrit euh François
Fillon est un homme politique comme tous
les hommes politiques on prépare ce
qu'on va dire euh si ça avait été s'il
avait oui mais dans l' bellement du
discours ça peut arriver que la langue
sauf que ce discours circule euh sur
dans dans dans son facebook euh et
aucune phrase n'a été retirée du
discours de François Fillon dans dans le
cadre de ce de du Facebook moi ce qui ce
que je déplore particulièrement dans ce
discours ce sont les propos qui ont été
tenus certes mais c'est aussi le fait
que les gens qui l'ont entendu ont
applaudi
euh voilà je il y a des choses qui
avance quand même la loi tira a permis
de de recentrer le curseur il y a des
choses qui se font alors fort
heureusement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
cette histoire fait partie d'Emmanuel
scolaire on enseigne la traite négrière
l'esclavage le retour en arrière serait
que ces pages d'histoire soit sorti
d'Immanuel le pire le pire serait que
cette histoire soit occultée euh quand
j'entends les propos de François Fillon
je pense que le risque est grand ironie
de l'histoire ces propos à lui à
François Filion s chef de gouvernement
ont été quand même prononcés à Sablé sur
ça où l'un de ses maères a été un
certain Raphaël Élisée alors c'est oui
c'est c'est assez alors ça ce sont les
subtilités de du du du contexte
effectivement Raphaël Élisée qui a été
maire de la commune dans laquelle il a
été élu lui-même François Fillon
euh c'est un homme qui a participé qui a
été rejeté à cause de sa couleur euh qui
a participé à la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et qui est mort qui a été en camp de
concentration et qui est mort
euh il est important voilà c'est c'est
un des aspects c'est-à-dire que quand il
parle dans son discours des héros de ces
héros euh il le savait pas ah je ne sais
pas s'il savait j'espère pour lui qu'il
le savait il était quand même dans une
commune où il a eu un mandat électif
j'aime à croire qu'il savait que d'où la
nécessité du savoir de l'enseignement de
la connaissance c'est important bientôt
nous allons commémorer le 11 novembre en
novembre il faut savoir c'est l'année de
Verdin de de la bataille de Verdin il
faut savoir que les martiniicais chaque
fois qu'il y a eu les martiniicaais ou
toutes les populations d'autrem chaque
fois qu'il y a eu un conflit là ils ont
été présents au côté des Français pour
rétablir l'honneur pour rétablir la
puissance de la France alors d'autres
que vont réagir il y a eu Gilber
l'historien euh que nous avons entendu
sur les antennes de la première il y a
eu le comité de voir de mémoire des
formations politiques comme le PPM les
socialistes et leur républiquain Fred
Michel Tirot hier ont condamné les
propos de François filon est-ce que
c'est suffisant est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
aller plus
loin les condamnés c'est déjà bien
euh ne pas réagir aurait été inquiétant
euh je pense que il faut que nous soyons
vigilants nous arrivons dans une et
c'est tout et c'est tout il faut que
nous soyons vigilants euh
peut pas aller plus loin une action
justice par exemple c'est c'est
envisageable pour de tels propos selon
vous je pense non il faut condamner ces
propos nous sommes dans un dans une
démocratie où nous pouvons effectivement
dire les choses comme nous voulons les
dire
euh il faut être vigilant sur les propos
qui sont tenus et chaque fois qu'il y a
des dérives il faut que nous soyons en
capacité de monter au créneau c'est le
silence
qui
risque le silence qui risque justement
de laisser faire et de laisser dire en
ce moment en France il y a une monté des
nationalismes il faut que nous soyons
vigilants nous faisons partie de cette
nation nous sommes partie intégrante et
donc nous devons dénoncer chaque fois
qu'il y a lieu à dénoncer merci Syvie
mélien d'être venu dans sacad on
rappelle que vous êtes historienne
historienne remoné après les propos de
François filon à la fin du mois d'aût à
tablé sur Sart merci d'avoir été avec
nous bonne journée